Boonen tapa is making dough Malou rajma
and fini lentils a spicy potato
specialty and rice pudding and not just
for herself and her husband Farhad today
it's 5 portions for the last two weeks
she's been cooking for the million
kitchen app developed by a startup
company in Delhi I do some extra money
costs arising my children are studying
and they don't have any income my
husband only earns around 12 thousand
rupees as a driver that's only around
160 euros a month
Poonam is putting her earnings from the
app aside to help pay for her children's
education she's proud that the people
who were ordering her food through the
app enjoy it those orders arrive here
first then a new job and some friends
brought the app to market this for the
first time in we were actually creating
a platform of sharing home-cooked food
and the process of sharing we're
actually creating a parallel economy
we're creating an economy for thousands
and thousands of women and men who never
thought that they would actually earn
money or their own recipe the food is
packed for delivery upon the roof in the
same building around 100 orders have
come in over the last two weeks
Henderson Gupta has written a book about
India's startup scene he says
entrepreneurship is anchored deeply in
people's psyches here but that the
government has to do more to support it
we have to cut down the time it takes to
set up a company in India that's number
one number two is infrastructure
entrepreneurship needs infrastructure it
needs 24/7 electricity right it needs
good roads it needs water and in large
parts of India all of these things are
not available fashion and you is a store
company in the Indian startup space it's
grown into one of the top ecommerce
platforms for style in the country the
focus was to add more than
brands in the kitty and that worked for
us because India as our country's quite
brand Hungarian coming at discount
really only gives the impetus to do more
sales that help and as for a sleepless
night as I think I didn't sleep over six
months flash sales offering huge
discounts on some articles for a limited
period of time helped run the startup
into a major player in the sector within
just five years fashion and you know
processes six thousand orders a day and
deploys five hundred staff whether it's
fashion or homemade food ecommerce is
booming in India even though only about
a quarter of its population has regular
access to the Internet